Donc, les maladies infectieuses
demeurent la cause principale
de la souffrance dans le monde.
Chaque année,
des millions de personnes meurent
de maladies, telles que le VIH,
la malaria, la tuberculose,
dans le monde, même aux USA.
Chaque année, des milliers d’Américains
meurent de la grippe saisonnière.
En tant qu’êtres humains,
nous sommes créatifs, non ?
Nous avons trouvé des moyens
de combattre toutes ces maladies
avec les vaccins et les médicaments.
Nous réalisons que...
Nous apprenons de ces expériences,
nous trouvons des solutions.
Nous pensions être les seuls à pouvoir faire ça.
C'est faux.
Nous ne sommes pas les seuls docteurs.
Nous savons que beaucoup d’animaux en sont capables.
Le chimpanzé, pas si différent de nous
sait faire usage des plantes,
pour venir à bout de ses parasites intestinaux.
Les dernières décennies nous ont montré
que d’autres animaux le font,
éléphants, porcs-épics, moutons, chèvres,
et j’en passe.
Plus intéressant encore, des recherches récentes
nous montrent que des insectes et d’autres animaux
avec de plus petits cerveaux, en sont aussi capables.
Comme nous le savons tous, le problème avec
les maladies infectieuses est que les pathogènes
ne cessent d’évoluer et que plusieurs traitements
que nous avons mis au point cessent d’être efficaces.
Ainsi donc, il nous est impérial de trouver
de nouvelles façons de produire des médicaments.
Je pense qu’il nous faut regarder de plus près
ces petits animaux,
pour découvrir de nouvelles façons de se protéger des maladies.
En tant que biologiste, j’étudie
le papillon monarque depuis 10 ans.
Ces papillons sont connus
pour leur extraordinaire migration du Mexique au Canada.
Chaque année, des millions se regroupent.
Ce n’est néanmoins pas la raison pour
laquelle je les étudie.
Les papillons monarques tombent malades
tout comme vous et moi.
Je pense que ce qu’ils font peut nous aider à developper
de nouvelles formes de médecines.
Les parasites qui infectent les papillons monarques
s’appellent ophryocystis elektrocirrha.
Pas facile à dire.
Ils produisent des millions de spores
qui enveloppent le papillon.
Ces spores forment de petites taches entre
les écailles des papillons.
C'est très dangereux pour le papillon car cela réduit
leur espérance de vie ainsi que leur capacité de vol.
Ça peut même les tuer avant qu’ils n’atteignent l’âge adulte.
C’est un parasite très nuisible.
Je passe une grande partie de mon temps
à faire pousser des plantes sous serre
car les papillons monarques sont des mangeurs très sélectifs.
Sous forme larvaire ils ne mangent que des laiterons.
Heureusement, ils peuvent utiliser plusieurs espèces de laiterons.
Toutes ces espèces contiennent des cardénolides.
Ces substances sont toxiques
pour la plupart des mammifères, mais pas pour les monarques.
En fait, les monarques peuvent absorber ces substances
et se rendre toxiques contre leurs prédateurs, tels que les oiseaux.
Ils vont ensuite mettre en valeur ces substances
au travers leurs couleurs de signalisation.
Ces splendides oranges, noirs et blancs.
Ce que j’ai donc le plus fait dans la serre,
est de faire pousser différentes plantes.
Certaines étaient toxiques, tel que le laiteron tropical
avec de très fortes concentrations de cardénolides.
D’autres n’étaient pas toxiques.
J’ai ensuite nourri les monarques avec.
Certains monarques étaient très sains, sans maladies,
d’autres étaient malades.
J'ai découvert que certains de ces laiterons ont des vertus médicinales
dans le sens où ils atténuent les symptômes du papillon monarque,
les faisant vivre plus longtemps une fois infectés
lorsqu’ils consommaient ces laiterons.
Une idée m’est donc venue, que beaucoup ont qualifiée de folle.
Je me suis dit que si les monarques peuvent utiliser ceci,
peuvent-ils utiliser ces plantes
comme forme de médicament à part entière ?
Sont-ils des docteurs ?
Mon équipe et moi-même avons commencé à faire des expériences.
Dans le premier cas, nous avons donné aux chenilles
des laiterons médicinaux, et d’autres, ordinaires,
et nous avons mesuré combien de chaque espèce de plantes
ils consommaient dans leur cycle de vie.
Comme souvent dans le monde de la recherche,
les résultats furent ennuyeux.
La moitié de leur alimentation était médicinale
et l’autre moitié ne l'était pas.
Ces chenilles ne prenaient pas soin de leur santé.
On s’est ensuite tourné vers les papillons adultes.
On se demandait si les mères soignaient les enfants.
Les mères peuvent-elles pondre leurs œufs
sur des laiterons médicinaux
ce qui rendrait leur progéniture moins malade ?
Depuis des années nous expérimentons en obtenant les même résultats.
On enferme un papillon dans une grande cage,
avec une plante médicinale d’un côté,
et une normale de l’autre.
On compte ensuite le nombre d’œufs laissés sur chaque plante.
On a observé que le résultat est toujours le même.
Les papillons préfèrent largement les plantes médicinales
Autrement dit, ce que font les femelles,
c’est de pondre 68% des œufs sur la plante
aux vertus médicinales.
Bizarrement, elles transmettent
le parasite lors de la ponte.
Elles ne peuvent s’empêcher car elles sont incapables
de se soigner elles-mêmes.
Ce que les expériences nous montrent, c’est que
les femelles papillons monarques
peuvent pondre leurs œufs sur des plantes médicinales,
ce qui rendra leurs progéniture moins malade.
Je pense que c’est une découverte fascinante,
pas seulement parce qu’elle nous montre
que la nature est belle mais aussi comment
nous pouvons découvrir de nouvelles façons
de créer des remèdes.
Ces animaux sont petits et on les perçoit trop souvent comme simples.
Ils ont de petits cerveaux
mais sont capables d’avoir leurs propres remèdes.
Nous savons que la plupart de nos médicaments
nous viennent de la nature et des cultures traditionnelles.
La médecine traditionnelle se tourne souvent vers
la nature et la façon de faire des animaux.
Ainsi, les éléphants nous ont enseigné
comment guérir des maux d’estomac,
les porcs épics, comment faire face aux diarrhées sanglantes.
Ce qui est important, je crois, est de voir
au-delà des animaux à gros cerveau
et d’apprécier les petits animaux tels que les insectes,
que nous avons trop souvent tendance
à mettre de côté du fait de leur petit cerveau.
Le fait de s’être rendu compte
qu'ils sont capables de se soigner
nous ouvre de nouvelles voies,
et je pense qu’un jour, nous soignerons
des maladies humaines avec des remèdes découverts par des papillons.
Je vois cela comme une chance
qui vaut la peine
d’être approfondie.
Merci à tous.
(Applaudissements)